اخوتي واخواتي الكرام عدنا لكم من جديد
معكم عبود واليوم حابب انقل صوره انا
شخصيا قاعد بعيشها واللي هي كارثه الامن
الغذائي واللي بنعاني منها في شمال القطاع
يا اخوان لو نطلع لاي انسان في هذه الدنيا
بنعرف انه بياكل ثلاث وجبات في اليوم
واللي هي فطور غدا عش معروفات اما الانسان
في قطاع غزه واللي بيختلف عن اي انسان على
هذه الدنيا فهو بياكل من نص وجبه لوجبه في
اليوم والله كمان اوقات ما بياكله متخيلين
اما عن موضوع الميه فهي احنا بنشرب ميه
غير صالحه للشرب اقوللكم يعني بياه
بالعميه ميه ملوثه وهذ اللي خلت نص الشعب
عيان وفي المستشفيات واقول لكم والله كمان
بمعناه ل نحصل عليها انتم متخيلين تعيشنا
بدون كهربا وتكنولوجيا بس صعب ان انا
نتعايش بدون اكل وشرب صحيح زوها لمنظومه
الغذاء
العالمي